[Music]
Ghana's local rice revolution takes
viewers through the thriving landscapes
of rice farms across the country,
highlighting the dynamic innovations and
success stories emerging in the
industry. The documentary showcases the
important roles played by young farmers
and processes while emphasizing the
significance of local rice production
for Ghana's economy by exploring various
stages of the rice value chain and
promoting local
consumption. This film encourages deeper
engagement in the country's agricultural
sector. The West African country's
fertile land holds the promise of
feeding the nation.